The hypotenuse is 25, the longer leg is 20, and the shorter leg is 15 units.
Great work for finding those three numbers. For a squared we'll have x minus 5
squared, for b squared we'll have x squared and for c squared we'll have the
quantity x plus 5 squared. Keep in mind a and b are the legs, and c is our
hypotenuse. Now we have one equation with one variable, which means we can
solve. Squaring the quantity x minus 5, we get x squared minus 10x plus 25, and
squaring the quantity x plus 5 squared, we get x squared plus 10x plus 25. This
x squared just comes straight down here. Next, we'll add like terms on the left
hand side of our equation to get 2x squared minus 10x plus 25. The right hand
side of our equation stays the same. And since we have a quadratic equation, we
want to move all of these terms to the left hand side so that we can get a
quadratic expression set equal to 0. We move each of these terms to the other
side of the equation by subtracting the appropriate amount. We'll subtract x
squared, subtract 10x, and subtract 25 from both sides of the equation. We do
this so that with the x squared term remains positive, and then we can factor.
This leaves us with x squared minus 20x equals 0. We can factor an x from these
two terms since it is the greatest common factor. So, of x times the quantity x
minus 20. We set each factor equal to 0. And then we solve for x. X can equal 0
or x can equal positive 20. Since we know we're talking about the side length
the longer leg must be 20. The 0 doesn't make sense in this case. So our longer
leg will be 20, our hypotenuse will be 5 more which is 25. And our shorter leg
will be five less which is 15.